[Music]
hey everybody welcome to planet coaster
college today I'll be talking about the
Schwarzkopf looping coaster also known
in game as the SLV and I know it's been
a while since I made a last episode in
this series but I really want to get
back to it for this coaster because well
partly it was named after me actually by
the guys at frontier which I can still
barely believe thanks so much for that
it's amazing and also and perhaps not
coincidentally it's one of my favorite
coaster types in the world it's an
amazing classic it's really smooth
despite how all these things are and
I'll probably get more into details
during the rest of this video and I
apologize in advance if I get extra
off-topic and on a bunch of very long
coaster ends I know that's what this
series is all about but today it might
be a little bit more than usual in any
case I requested this coaster at some
Danny a little over a year ago in London
together with @fo TV and I'm pretty sure
it's been very often requested from the
rest of the community as well so to see
it being here put into the game for the
DLC is really amazing so basically
what's a swatch Cup abouts if you're not
too into roller coasters you might be
wondering what the hell I'm talking
about and why this is such a big deal so
swatch Cove is known generally as one of
the pioneers in the entire roller
coaster industry it's well really both a
person and a company really were talking
about untold Schwarzkopf who's pretty
much the lead designer and the head of
the company but it's his company that
built the coasters in the end and well
one of his biggest achievements probably
is the creation of the steel looping
coaster the very first vertical looping
in a cloth or shape I do have to say I
set this statement before and it wasn't
actually the verse the first vertical
looping there were wooden coasters and
still
before that with a circular vertical
looping but the modern vertical looping
with a cloth Lloyd shape as we know it
today was first used by a white cop
coaster specifically revolution in Six
Flags Magic Mountain which is also one
of my favorites watch coughs is an
awesome coaster and I really loved it in
any case it's a classic for that very
reason when a lot of people think of a
traditional steel looping coaster this
is probably what they are thinking about
it's the standard looping coaster in the
roller coaster tycoon games it's very
common in Fairgrounds and theme parks
around the world for lots of people I
know this was their first coaster to go
upside down or at the very least their
first coaster to have vertical looping
in it and just over all these things
have been around for so long the first
vertical looping coaster by Schwarzkopf
of the looping star model which is
pretty much the kind of coaster that
we'll be talking about today
was built in 1978 and to this day these
coasters still hold up they're pretty
smooth they're still really thrilling
and among coaster enthusiasts there are
some of the favorite rides I should also
say that they have a bit of a unique
track type and this is also why this has
been so much requested it's really hard
to make these kinds of coasters if you
don't have the specific track type so
they have a very distinct look with a
round spine in the middle and then
almost at the same height two rails and
the sides and what's interesting is that
this type of track was very popular not
just because well the guests of the
parks wanted it but because it was very
useful for the parks and the families
that traveled around Fairgrounds putting
their coasters there because it's a type
of track that you can very easily take
apart and reassemble so for that purpose
and because of that it's one of the most
common traveling coasters and some of
the biggest and best traveling coasters
in the world are all short scoffs now I
could name a few examples I don't want
to go on for too long before I actually
start building stuff but definitely the
most noteworthy one I think is Olympia
looping it's a travelling coaster with
five loopings it's my personal favorite
to watch coughs
it's really intense it's insanely
intense actually it has over five g's at
the bottom of those loops because the
loops are a little bit more circular
than other vertical loops tend to be
they get ridiculous high g-forces at the
bottom of them and it's a really cool
experience and aside from that I think a
few other noteworthy ones are revolution
in Six Flags Magic Mountain there's a
Leesburg ban on in Lisa barrack in
Sweden which was one of the last ones
and doesn't actually feature a loop but
it's still a really cool track even even
despite that I think and then there are
tons and tons of the looping star model
which was a sort of copy-paste
off-the-shelf model which traveled a lot
across the world and which is probably
the most common of this type of coaster
now I didn't want to dwell on this for
too long so I suggest that we just start
building because there are so many
different types of these coasters but
most of them are known as travelling
coasters or at the very least are built
to be able to travel around I'm gonna
try to build a traveling model here so
it's gonna sit on a very small footprint
and I'm gonna try to make it as compact
as possible and at the same time I'm
gonna try to build a bit of a mixture of
the existing ones because there are so
many different variations so I'm just
gonna try and pick and choose a little
bit from all the different ones so you
can sort of get the general idea of what
these things would look like so let's
get started so we can find the SLV under
the coasters tab of course it should sit
right over here and I should also note
it is also a shuttle coaster as it says
but I'm just gonna focus on the general
layouts in this case if you want to
build a shuttle though there are tons of
amazing shuttles in the world as well
and you can probably find a few good
examples of it my favorite personal is a
psyche and ER ground in wallaby Belgium
that could probably serve as a pretty
good example but usually the shuttle
coasters just go back and forth with a
loop and then two ends of the track
where it goes up and down so it's not
too complicated so I really want to
focus on a more calm
continuous circuits kind of coaster here
so let's take the station and I think
this is a pretty decent length although
right at the start I do want to add
actually another station square to it so
yeah we get six cars that should be
pretty good and I should also say
normally I always raise my stations
quite a bit from the ground but in this
case a lot of these coasters are quite
close to the ground in their station so
this should pretty much be okay and you
can already see there's a lot of options
down here so I'm gonna quickly go over
most of them here we have the basic
track this is what you see most of the
coasters have most of the time then
there's also the more simple track which
takes away some of those smaller track
ties and I tried for a very long time to
find any information about this
specifically on the internet I really
couldn't find anything but it seems to
just be about the stress that's put on
the track so a lot of coasters will sort
of switch between the standard track and
the alternate track but most of the
coasters especially the larger ones have
the standard track for most of their
layouts I think a few examples are the I
believe it's called the Silver Arrow
model which is a very small model it's
smaller than most swatch cups and it
only uses the alternate track and Lisa
backbone on in this event is also
another coaster that has the one without
the extra ties but in this case I'm just
gonna keep the expertise throughout the
layout since the focus is here really on
the layout itself then there's also the
flat track which you can use for the
less large coasters or brake runs or
whenever you want to use that for and
then there's the shuttle launch booster
which we won't be concerned with right
now but if you want to use that it
basically goes to this part and then it
launches it backwards and then finally
forwards again when it comes through
this station again and then I will just
do its shuttle thing then there's a
wheel lifts which is a lift Hill with
wheels and there's also a chain lift and
you can really use both of these it
doesn't really matter too much I think
it kind of depends on what you're going
for a lot of swatch cup coasters are are
pretty well known for having
lift hills with curves in them but it
actually doesn't seem to matter whether
you have a chain lift or a wheel lifts
because they're both curved lift hills
with chains and curved lift hills with
wheels in this case I'm gonna go for a
wheel one like on for instance the
Mindbender in Canada and Olympia looping
but then there are also Drive tires
which you can just use to push the
terrain forward an interesting note here
I always put a lot of stress on the fact
that you should never have coaster
sections which are completely straights
because the coaster should always be
allowed to coast where none of the
wheels or brakes are working but Swach
cope is a notable exception here all of
the break runs etc are entirely
straights and then we have friction
brakes to slow it down and the trim
brakes of course to slow it down a
little bit less and the block sections
which are going to be important to
divide that a coaster into multiple
trains so with that said I would like to
try a little bit of a curved lift over
here and I'm gonna turn on angle snap
just because that makes my life a little
bit easier and go in about 22.5 degrees
upwards and to build that sort of large
lift Hill curve I'm just gonna build a
12 meter piece and go up with a 45
degree curve like that and that should
pretty much be a decent curved lift so
it's pretty big I do have to say but
then again I'm gonna try to build a
pretty big coaster here so let's bring
it down to the top of the lift over here
and actually I forgot to do this so far
I should probably add that and a little
catwalk along the side of the lift over
here there we go and then we are pretty
much good to go I would say I can
actually make this a little bit more
like that so I'm gonna turn off the
catwalk here and start work on the lift
soon or actually start work on the rest
of the layouts so because this is a
transportable coaster I'm gonna try and
stay between the lift Hill and the
station so what you'll see a lot of
swatch Cove coasters do is to really
have
the brakes and the station and the lift
Hill on the outside of the layouts and
then the entire rest of the layouts all
of the loops and curves and everything
kind of fits within that space so they
are extremely compact and then we're
gonna turn on a little bit of banking
offset and I should be a bit careful
here because banking offsets is Orwell
hard lining the different word for it is
a very recent thing it's very much done
by computers nowadays and these coasters
tend to be very much calculated by hand
or at the very least not designed with
the use of computers like we do nowadays
and they were strictly speaking not hard
lined but what's interesting about a lot
of swatch golf coasters is that they
sort of seem to have an intuitive hard
line to them because they are somewhat
smooth and they almost sort of
transition as if there was a hard line
even though there wasn't really any so I
think much cop probably knew or to some
extent understood how to move into
curves while making it also a little bit
smooth so I'm just gonna have a little
bit of banking offsets here and when we
go down for the drop we don't want to go
too steep directly so usually they kind
of slowly transition into their first
drop so I'm gonna try and do something
similar here and let's just keep going
steeper and steeper it doesn't matter
too much if it's not very smooth for one
these coasters aren't super smooth to
begin with they have generally smooth
layouts but then the transitions from
one track piece to another because they
are so old isn't always the best but I'm
gonna smooth it out later much more
anyway so don't worry too much about
that yet all right so now we're gonna
try and get a bit of a circle going here
where it flattens out parallel to the
station we're also leaving it's a bit of
space next to the station what I'm gonna
try to do is just go down for a curve
over here and then come straight back up
for a block break section which is
something that you'll see a lot of these
kind of coasters too right so as I am
coming down here I want to bank a little
bit less
if you have a steep curve coming down
like this
you definitely want to get rid of a lot
of your banking all right there we go
that should be decent although I could
maybe Bank it a little bit more than
that this looks it's highly a bit unsafe
all right let's try that again
and oops then we're gonna come back up
again and what's interesting is that
these kinds of curves they are very much
banked while you're in the drop and then
when you're at the bottom it's less
banked and then we are going up again
the steeper it is the more banked it
also often is and this is all just kind
of intuitively trying to minimize the
lateral g-forces that you feel as a
rider alright so something like that
should more or less do the job
I'm gonna try and come back to this
place over here without being straight
underneath the lift cell so yeah I'm
just gonna see what works here so what
you see with a lot of these coasters is
that you've got the lift so and then
there are a lot of brake runs straight
on the lifts underneath a little so
there might be a brake run here and
there might be a brake run here all
horizontal and all almost directly
underneath the lift Hill because a lot
of these will be travelling coasters and
they want to have the maximum throughput
and capacity as they can so these are
all block sections defining the coaster
into different blocks so you can run a
lot of trains on them so I think Olympia
looping for instance can run five trains
despite the fact that it's a travelling
coaster and despite the fact that it's
really so super compact so having all of
these brake runs basically allows the
coaster to have many different strains
on its and be much more efficient and
for a coaster that travels around on
Fairgrounds and needs to make its money
out of selling tickets that's a pretty
important thing you definitely don't
want a line to form there and you want
to get as many guests as you can go
through it alright I think I've figured
that out now it's time to add a block
section already over here let's try to
make that
long enough for a train to at least
decently fit on that and it's gonna
remove the supports on the top there but
don't worry too much about that we're
gonna need to fix that anyway because
then a lot of coasters like this
basically they work in a sense that
everything is going to be built on the
supports of the track parts above it so
you'll have supports coming down here
and this track will basically be hanging
on to that as well at least that's what
you see with a lot of these coasters and
said I could probably actually raise
this quite a bit more let me just see if
I can go up a little bit here and let's
start a little bit of a test so this
first part is a little bit of a teaser I
would say for the rest of the ride
because it's super shorts but still
pretty intense it's definitely really
intense with how not so smooth it is
over there and that's actually smooth
and out a little bit more so with this
because we have some delicates banking
going on on the sides here especially
over here and it can actually Bank that
a little bit more even maybe I would
suggest to mess around a little bit with
the different kinds of banking that we
now have so try a bit of heights a bit
of turn banking but mostly probably
Heights banking in our case and then
only at the end to bring it all together
a little bit over over all smooth all
banking but the problem with smooth or
banking with this is that you can get
rid of a lot of well banking basically
which is kind of annoying and we don't
want that to happen so in this case it's
actually not even banked enough anymore
down here at the bottom of the curve so
I'm just gonna have to let's write that
again but it looks alright enough I
suppose let's see so it's coming down
over there we can always see about that
later I'm actually gonna have to look at
the g-forces here because as much as I
like to get close to 5 I don't really
want it to go over 5 here so let's see
about those vertical g-force because it
looks bit dangerous and okay that's just
my rights all right yeah that's pretty
good so you kind of want the the right
to be painful every now and then
sometimes these things get way too many
vertical tees at the bottom of their
drops but that's more or less what I was
looking for
so let's keep going so now I suggest we
bring it back down here and start going
into some loopings maybe that'd be nice
so a very general way of looking at what
coffe coasters that I was recommended by
Meno so thank you very much for this by
the way Meno that was actually really
cool advice is to look at it like a
circle or like a set of three circles
we've got one circle over here we've got
our middle circles sort of following
over here and then another circle here
now the smaller models will typically be
two circles so they're kind of like an
eight-figure circuits going back and
forth but in our case since this is a
pretty big model I think we can pretty
much make three circles so after the
break run I'm gonna do some something a
little bit sketchy which you see a lot
of these coasters do so we're gonna go
down a little bit and we're gonna go up
again and that should give us enough
room okay maybe we're gonna do this a
little bit quicker so maybe with six
meter pieces like that but just enough
leeway so that we can start making the
third circle and after that's done we
can add some break runs perhaps at the
end to see where that can that stuff can
go all right so let's finish it like
this and make it come down with a big
sweeping curve and then in the middle
somewhere we can have two loopings I
think that would be nice all right looks
like a pretty decent curve so far and
I'm gonna have to be very careful
actually I'm gonna build the brake run
first just to get a bit of a guideline
because I want to be as close as
possible to the already existing track
pieces as I can but at the same time of
course I don't want to run into myself
here so I'm gonna have to build a little
bit more of this here see how much of
the way we have to build the loop
alright that's that's pretty fair I
think we can work with that
so these coasters will often come very
close to their earlier track sections so
I'm not gonna be too concerned about
that here I just want to make sure that
it lines up pretty well and it's
just about parallel with the station all
right so we want to start losing that
Bank over here looks pretty good and
then maybe already get into a loop here
into the other direction there we go oh
yeah I think that's pretty decent just
gonna have to see how tall we can
actually make that definitely not that
tall
I think actually I need to move a tiny
bits inside here but we're generally on
the right track I think no pun intended
yeah that just about looks parallel to
the station's rank actually that's
perfect God Wow all right let's keep
going then I'm just not sure about the
size of that loop it probably needs to
be quite a bit bigger so I'm gonna try
to bring that down to a little bit lower
than the break section that we just had
and then it should be fine I think so
what I'm also gonna do is I'm gonna have
a tiny bit of a straight section here in
the middle I know it's not the best
looking thing but I've seen it on a fair
amount of these kinds of coasters in
real life although if I can fit it in
with the outer section like that that
would actually be much better hold on a
second let's see if we can do that and I
think that just barely fits I'm gonna
have to make this loop a little bit
smaller than the one before that's it
shouldn't be too noticeable but it
should stay at the same sort of speed as
the first loop so something like that
and I always like to look at the skyline
of these coasters as well because
they're gonna be at this play you know
they're gonna be traveling around and
you're gonna want to see them and you're
gonna want to have a pretty nice view of
the coaster from the front as well so I
think that over there is just about what
we're looking for so I think that's a
pretty decent start to the shape of the
coaster we can fill in the rest of the
coaster by putting a helix here a helix
here maybe a bit of a transition here I
don't think there's quite space for a
helix oh you don't very often see that
right in the
but it's a pretty good start and now
let's start bringing her back up by
curving along with the lift Hill with
this sort of circle that we're trying to
envision in our minds here if you will
and see if we can fit a little break run
underneath the lift so here so I'm gonna
be a little bit cheeky here and do
something else that you sometimes see on
these coasters sometimes instead of
having the little dip and heel after the
break run you can also see it before the
break run so I'm gonna try and do that
for a little bit here just to dive
underneath this section which we have
earlier and I'm gonna have to check
whether the clearance on that is
actually good enough but if it is that's
pretty good because these things are
always so compact and tightly woven all
right so let's see oh yes that is
definitely good enough close enough
where you can see the track being ready
to close then at least closer than it
normally is on a coaster but I think
it's still good so let's go for that now
that's fine and dandy but so far we've
only been taking right turns so I think
it's right about time to start moving
into different directions so what
usually works but now I have to kind of
check that again because it's getting a
little bit tight here so maybe I'm gonna
have to shorten this break section a
little bit but what usually works and
what you see a lot of these coasters do
is the kind of crisscross from side to
side so in this case it's probably a
good idea to dive straight down here and
then make a turn to the left at the
bottom of this and if you think there's
not enough space for that so if you
think it's a little bit too tight that's
exactly what we're looking for
usually I find myself thinking for a
split second when I write these things
in real life you know when you look down
at the curve that you're going down into
it just feels like there's not enough
space it just feels like it's way too
tight and it's gonna be painful and
usually it is maybe a little bit painful
and a little bit weird but really that's
what these coasters are all about so
let's get into a very tight turn over
here and see if we can make anything out
of it all right so that's pretty steep
actually but let's try it anyway
hopefully that'll be good
and start banking a little bit during
this transition so this is gonna have to
be pretty heavily banked as well I kind
of want to pause it for a second here
see if we can actually gets g-forces
which a human can survive down here
because it might get a little bit too
dangerous actually I kind of feel like
torturing the guests you know what I
think it's probably fun to really build
this into an actual helix yeah let's
just go for that let's just build a
helix it's gonna be pretty intense but
if it works then it's gonna be great and
as you start going up you also want the
banking to pull out a little bit all
right that's a little bit crazy so
actually let's see if it takes it
alright so far we're still all good but
this might be a tiny bit dangerous well
other g-forces are actually mostly fine
so yeah let's just keep it in now let's
keep following the sort of circular
shape that we've established earlier so
that doesn't mean we need to form a
perfect circle here but we do want to
make a turn to the right somewhere in
the middle of this so I think at this
point it's a good idea to have as a
section which goes kind of straight ish
sort of like this and then have a
transition in there to a piece which is
going to the rights actually I would
probably divide it into two pieces just
to make smoothing a little bit easier so
something like this should work and also
don't be afraid to kind of over Bank
that a little bit but since we're
following the general curve sort of
layouts of the track I think we're on
pretty good layout here yeah something
like that and we'll start to unpack it a
little bit here and then get into
another one of these transition pieces
now these transitions are usually the
parts where these coasters get a little
bit rough in real life since the
transition of going from a banked curved
piece to a straights and opposite bengts
piece is always a little bit hard so if
that's a little bit rough I would say
it's pretty much just how it's supposed
to be
and as we come down lower we can
decrease the incline a little bit and
get into very tight narrow helix down
here actually I could make that maybe
even a little bit tighter because it's
already slowing down quite a bit and
this is probably partly due to the block
brakes so I'm actually gonna get back to
that and set them to slightly higher
speed as well that would probably be
good but still we can have the coaster
go a little bit faster than this
honestly all right awesome and if all
goes well we will be whoo that's
actually really tight hold up I'm gonna
have to bring that maybe a little bit
lower expand that piece a bit over here
and then we'll go out sort of leave the
curve already during the helix so they
have a little bit more space to
transition out of it and then if we
cross to the other side here we'll be
more or less following this sort of
circular shape that we have there so
that's perfect
all right now we're getting toward the
end of the track and I do want to make
sure that all of this is parallel and
completely straight so I'm gonna start
working from the end again and just have
this curve around actually that can be a
little bit closer to the only existing
track maybe something like that will
probably work yep and then we really are
perfectly underneath the lift Hill or
actually the second drop over here so
that's pretty much exactly what I'm
looking for let's just have some trim
breaks maybe over here to bring it down
to a decent speed actually just friction
makes friction brakes we'll probably do
because I'm gonna have to decrease the
speed by quite a bit and then we'll
maybe have some trim breaks on a bit of
a slope to transition into this part all
right now I didn't smooth anything
oh it's besides the first drop yet so
let's take this whole curve smooth that
out a little bit I don't want to quite
grab this yet because I don't want to
pull it along with the curve but this
should be good enough
smooth that outs actually increase the
bank on that a little bit as well all
right that looks pretty good and let's
do the same for this side
it's actually increase the banking a
little bit more because smoothing will
always get rid of some of your banking
so you always have to adjust this while
you're doing this moving so something to
also note about smoothing is that it
will always make all of your helixes a
little bit smaller so it's gonna
increase the g-forces on this a tiny bit
as well just something to keep in mind
and then for this because I want all of
these transitions to be a little bit
smoother I think I'm just gonna grab all
of this at the same time smooth out the
height smooth out the turn a little bit
and then we'll do a smooth or quickly
but not too much and that's already the
final parts
now I'm gonna fine tune this a little
bit so this is definitely not going to
be all this smoothing but at some point
all you want to do is just go back to
all the different pieces try a POV see
what it looks like and just hit some
extra smooth on the sections which
didn't quite look right or maybe even
redo them a little bit but then again
for this kind of coaster I'm not really
too concerned about it all right so I
could probably get it to be a little bit
smoother than it is right now but I
think we're at a decent level and I also
don't want to sacrifice too much of the
shaping in terms of the smoothing
because very often the smoother you make
your coaster the the more you lose of
the signature shaping and in this case I
do want to keep those very snappy
transitions from the heavily banked
sections over here into this straight
over here or this kind of quick
transition into the very steep helix so
we have the first drop over there which
has some high G's but nothing too bad I
think and then transitioning into the
part with the two loopings here and we
again get some pretty high forces but
nothing very high and typical about
these sort of circular loops is that you
get very high forces here but less
forces at the top of the loop so you
really sort of feel as though you're
going through a circle which is
something that I personally really like
the loops are definitely my favorite
parts of these kinds of rides and then
some really strong helix is actually
ridiculously strong over here I'm
to maybe make that he looks a bit bigger
because that did get smaller with
smoothing and this one is more or less
fine this is actually more of what
you're looking for maybe a long
sustained 3 to 3.5 GS I think something
like that is pretty reasonable this one
hits 5g at some point so I might need to
make that a little bit bigger again it
can definitely expand a bit into over
here so yeah I think there's a lot to be
improved on this ride but the general
idea still stands I think it's a
rectangular compact layouts with a set
of almost three circles that it's kind
of rotating around we've got the almost
circular loops in the front here and
some transitions sort of back and forth
a zig zagging to make sure that we don't
take the curve in the same direction
every single time and then there's just
some other stuff to play around with
like these straight sections that sort
of transition from a curve into another
because these coasters couldn't really
smoothly blend from one curve into
another like the modern
computer-generated coasters can some
very tights helixes with high G's maybe
not as high as this one but generally
that's something that you're looking for
as well and then a layout with very much
the lift Hill at the back of it you know
this would be sort of where you'd be
looking at the coaster from and then a
bunch of break runs sort of underneath
that's and if you were to get into more
of the scenery aspects of its a support
structure which supports the lift Hill
but then also has the break runs
underneath it basically attached to the
same supports as well so yeah overall I
am pretty happy with the lay notes it's
not perfect but it's a pretty decent
idea I would say of what a swatch cup
coaster at least the travelling models
are like so I'm gonna take some time for
myself here to theme this thing but I
think it'd be interesting to time-lapse
that so I haven't really done this much
before but I'm gonna give this thing a
bit of a makeover a bit of a different
color scheme and then some supports and
perhaps a small station and then we'll
see what it looks like in the end
now I want to give you guys a heads up I
will be spending the next 15 minutes
building supports for this coaster and I
would also like to add this is also
excluding some of the footage which I
didn't end up recording as well as some
of the research that I did to try and
figure out how to build supports so
after all this is a very time-consuming
process and I'd like to warn you guys
that you don't have to do this
when you build a swatch cup coaster you
really don't have to force this onto
yourself a lot of these coasters weren't
really transportable anyway so in that
case you can pretty much just keep the
in-game supports but in this case
because I wanted to make this as if it
were a transportable swatch cup coaster
and I wanted to see what these support
structures would be like I decided to
look a little bit into it and try to
recreate at least to the extent that I
could and that I could within this one
video and also that I could with some of
the resources that I had on the internet
trying to find out how these supports
work I tried to well recreates the
swatch cough support structure as much
as possible and I want to give a huge
shout outs here also to King rct3 as he
is known on YouTube at the very least
who's been a different of mine for a
long time and I decided to send him a
message yesterday just complaining about
the fact that I could barely find
anything on the Internet in terms of
resources about watch cup coasters and
he ended up going on a bit of a
researching spree along with me as well
and apparently the Olympia looping
coaster was the favorite coaster to
support according to until - watch cope
himself so that in the end I decided
would be the best coaster to look into
and to try and base these supports on
and what you really find is that the
supports overall kind of follow the
shape of the coaster itself remember how
I talked about the structure of having
three circles almost within the
rectangular layout of the coaster so
what you see if you look at a picture of
Olympia looping from an aerial
perspective is that you've got these
supports on the ground that connect all
of the supports and they also extend
from the middle of these circles almost
in sort of radius exactly following the
different curves which makes a lot of
sense
because all the curves they all sort of
rotate around this single centre point
so all of the supports kind of just come
out from this area as well but in
essence it means that you're trying to
build two support systems at a time and
you always have to keep these sort of in
sync so at once I'm building these white
supports to support the coaster make
sure that it's not actually floating in
mid-air but I'm also using the blue
supports which have to connect all of
these different supports and a support
can't just go into the ground it always
have to has to connect to these blue
beams and preferably you want to have as
many parts of the track connect to the
same support as you can so over here for
instance at the lift Hill this was
pretty easy to do because I made sure to
put the brake runs straight underneath
the lift Hill so all I have to do is try
and figure out where I could place the
beams in such a sense that they could
connect the different tracks while also
not running into the cars itself there
should always be enough clearance so
that the car or you know that you're not
decapitating people or something like
that so that was easy enough but then
there are also parts where especially
around the curves and the different
transitions the supports get little bit
more wonky and probably also a little
bit less realistic there wasn't so much
of a reference in terms of real-life
coasters of what I should base that on
but after all I think that's what made
this into a slightly more difficult
process than just supporting a regular
coaster
but even then it's it was still
something fun to try and I think it was
definitely worthwhile to try a support
structure like this what was also
interesting by the way King r63 also
found some patterns of swatch cop just
trying to find out about the track ties
because I originally sent him a message
asking about the track ties so this is
something that I mentioned at the start
of the video if you compare the first
track type and the second track type in
planet coaster the first one is the
regular the original one which has these
little tiny beams between the rails just
above the spine and the second one is
the same but without these tiny beams
and I could never find out what these
little beams were for they really seemed
to be for extra supports and this is
also what planet coaster says so King
rct3 started looking around couldn't
find anything on the patterns of the
track type so the the sort of cone plug
as they call it track type which is so
easy to dismantle and put together so
couldn't find anything about that but
according to his friend who is an
industrial designer apparently the tiny
ties are for employee purposes being
able to climb onto the track and to act
as a sort of ladder which makes sense I
think actually if you look at it they're
sort of placed at an interval which
definitely makes it much easier for
people to him to hang onto that
so perhaps but you know this is all just
as sort of a anecdotal evidence and not
really a super trustworthy source I
suppose but perhaps it seems like these
extra track tiles weren't for supports
but really for maintenance reasons for
allowing stuff to climb onto the track
and go wherever they needed to go and
whatever kind of emergency which is
really interesting and I think in the
end it's not something to worry about
too much really but I thought I was
worth looking into and thanks also to
King rct3 for looking into this for me
because
it's been on my mind for quite a while
now I've been working on this video for
a few days and it's something which you
just don't really find on the Internet
speaking of finding stuff on the
Internet I also really need to thank a
certain website which has a lot of
different kinds of information about
swatch cup its swatch cup coaster nets
with between swatch coffee and coaster
there's a - and it has all kinds of
different tabs about the history and
about the different track types and
about the coasters and its overall I
think the best place to find information
about this really interesting company on
the Internet and it is a bit of a
slightly old website though I think and
like everything it's not that well
sourced it's not a very academic
reference I suppose but it's it's really
interesting to read through everything
and it's where I got most of my
knowledge from before I started working
on this video and when I was doing some
basic research to look into the company
a little bit more so yeah there's all
that in the meantime I've got a lot more
support work done in the end this
actually turn out to be quite fun and
the way that I ended up going about it
was to just create a very general idea
of where I wanted all of the different
supports to be by laying out that
network of the blue-ish beams at the
bottom and then just trying to fit all
the white ones on that and what I found
actually becomes really easy you do to
doing it like this is that normally for
a coaster you kind of have to work out
where you want to place the supports to
actually place enough supports and it's
always a bit of a struggle to kind of
make that match up but in this case it's
kind of just like you pick a blue beam
and then you see what part of the track
goes above that and what other parts of
the track are close to that and then you
just build off of that every time it's
just picking a blue beam building a
support there and supporting all of the
track which is anywhere around that area
which is a kind of a fun way of doing it
it gives you a bit more of a guideline
of where you want to build so I thought
that was quite interesting I should also
note
the game gives me some footers for the
loop supports and I'm gonna keep these
in unfortunately if I were to be
completely realistic I would have to
build a kind of casing to place these
big funky loop supports in because these
are quite big and heavy and you can sell
on the transportable support structure
but in the game's case you automatically
get some footers and I don't want to
remove those either because the in game
loop supports are absolutely perfect and
I wouldn't be able to build anything
better myself but it just means that the
loop supports are gonna look as though
they were permanence instead of
transportable which shouldn't be too
much of a nuisance I guess but it's it
attracts a little bit from the realism
of the support work of the coaster I
suppose in any case I so far I was just
working on the lift Hill structure and
everything that's kind of close to that
so that was pretty easy but in this case
I had to do it a little bit differently
and working on the different transitions
and like I said this was a little bit
harder than doing the lift Hill so what
I ended up doing is picking those sort
of vertical beams or rather the
horizontal beams that cut across the
layouts and placing supports along those
and after that taking away the beams and
connecting the different supports
together to try and get as few footers
as I could in the general layout of the
support network and still I'm not
entirely sure how realistic this is but
this is largely based on Olympia looping
and what the supports for Olympia
looping looked like so overall I think
I'm pretty happy with it but I do have
to say I got a lot more respect than I
already had because I already respected
these things a lot but my respect is
gone up so much just by trying to do
this for all of these different
transportable coasters because building
a coaster that can actually travel
around and be built and dismantled in
any given time
that's insanely difficult the amount of
engineering that goes into this and the
amount of thoughts that had to be put
into all of the different supports like
everything in this thing works together
the the placement of the track the way
that the layouts sort of falls in and
out of itself the way that all the
supports work together everything was
created in in sort of us well working
together because not only did the layout
have to be fun it also had to be easy to
create and dismantle and had to fit with
the support structure so it's a really
impressive work of engineering I think
so yeah hats off to whoever built this
coaster together with swatch cope and
also to the people who are still
travelling this coaster around because
for how old well I'm saying this coaster
really I had Olympia looping in mind for
how old that thing is it's still amazing
how well it holds up and it's gonna be a
sad day when they finally decide to not
let it let its travel around anymore and
when nobody wants it in any case we're
getting near the end of the time-lapse
here I'm just finishing up the coaster a
little bit with some flags and other
decorations and trying to build a very
simple park around it but that's not
really the focus here my goal here is to
basically look at make it look
presentable for the intro of the video
so at this point my work is pretty much
done let's go back for a final real-time
session and look at the coaster go
around and then I'll call it a day I
think for the tutorial parts of this
video we're pretty much done all right
so here we are this is pretty much the
coaster as you saw it in the intro as
well and it's more or less finished I
could have obviously done a lot more
when it comes to the scenery around it
but and it's just for planet coaster
College here in any case I'm pretty
happy with the layouts one thing that I
should probably have said somewhere
during the rest of my video but I still
want to bring up in the end is that as
much as these coasters are very typical
for very typically a design of swatch
Cove they are closely linked to vanished
angle as well whose
someone who's been extremely influential
in the roller coaster industry and I
couldn't even begin to describe how much
this man has influenced the the entire
way in which roller coasters are being
made for one he more or less pioneered
the idea of heart lining and worked very
closely together with swatch Kampf so a
lot of the especially early swatch coke
coasters are so typically swatch cop not
just because of the company itself but
also because of vanish'd angle its
involvement in engineering and
calculating these rights and doing all
of that sort of hard science stuff that
I don't know a lot about in any case
that's just about it for this episode so
I hope you guys somehow managed to stay
awake during this entire run I know that
I'm definitely almost falling asleep
right now but um yes thank you so much
to frontier for giving this coaster to
the game as well and for naming it after
me which is absolutely amazing I hope
you guys learned something from this
huge video or that it was at least
entertaining ball in some way and I'm
gonna get back into some regularly
scheduled videos although maybe I do
want to bring back planet coaster
college a little bit more aside from
just this video as well we'll see in any
case thanks for watching bye bye